yes the house is not past that you were
here the the relief billing as you
sounding it probably tonight as you know
there's no aid to states and localities
in that bill mental Mitch McConnell of
course has talked about States seeking
bankruptcy protection
he's also his office referred to this is
a the idea of 18 states is a blue state
bailout what do you say to that do you
agree with that or you agree with
Governor Cuomo that that is a vicious
attack on these states that is attacked
but certainly some people do look at it
that way I've spoken to Mitch about it
I've spoken to numerous senators about
it and we're working with senators that
are on the other side of the issue and
we'll see what happens but we're looking
to do what's right for the people of
this country we're looking to do what's
right for a particular state and we'll
see what happens but it's certainly the
next thing we're going to be discussing
because some states have in all fairness
join some states have not done very well
for many years so long before the virus
came you know you can't blame the plague
this horrible plague that came in and
all of a sudden you know they can't
blame that you look at Illinois he's got
a lot of problems long before the virus
came in and so we'll be talking about it
it'll be a subject for a period of time
and right now we've we've made this
incredible deal for the workers and for
small business and I'm very happy that
Harvard didn't get covered we actually
never sent them the check but they were
very nice about it we never sent him the
the money the old-fashioned where's the
check the new way has sent him the money
and we didn't send him the money and but
they were very understanding and they
were very nice about it so was Princeton
so was Stanford so were a number of
other schools that you just don't
associate with this money so were big
companies as you know you know many of
them it was a relatively small amount of
money compared to the whole very small
amount of money compared but we want it
to be fair we want it to go to the
people that are supposed to go to ideas
that are going to be great for the
people of this country
if we can help States we're always going
to help States now there's different
ways of helping States some ways are
better than others so we're looking it
is interesting that the states that are
in trouble do happen to be blue
it is interesting you know if you look
around I mean the states that seem to
have the problem happened to be Democrat
and Jersey got hit by this you know a
lot of trouble long before the plague
came and they were you know a lot of
problems long before the play came I
spoke with Governor Cuomo Bevin spoke to
governor Murphy about it I spoke with
Gavin Newsom about it and we speaking to
a lot of people about it because it's
probably gonna be the next thing on the
list a lot of people understand very
well what mitch is saying and they also
understand the other side of the the
problem and I'll be speaking about it
we're going to do the right thing for
our country the right thing for our
country and the right thing for a lot of
great people okay yes for president
after the presentation we just saw about
the heat and the humidity is it
dangerous for you to make people think
they would be safe by going outside in
the heat considering that so many people
are dying in Florida considering that
this virus has had an outbreak in
Singapore places that are gone and are
you the new the new headline is Trump as
people to go outside that's dangerous
here we go
same old group you ready I hope people
enjoy the Sun and if it has an impact
that's great
I'm just hearing this not really for the
first time and there's been a rumor that
you know a very nice room or that you go
outside of the zone or you have heat and
it does have an effect on other viruses
but now we get it from one of the great
laboratories of the world I have to say
covers a lot more territory than just
this is this is probably an easy thing
relatively speaking for you I would like
you to speak to the medical doctors to
see if there's any way that you can
apply light and heat to cure you know if
you could and maybe you can maybe you
can't again I say maybe you can maybe a
can't I'm not a doctor but I'm like a
person that has a
you know what never have you ever heard
of that the heat and the light relative
to certain viruses yes but relative to
this virus that is a treatment I mean
certainly fever kill is a good thing
when you have a fever it helps your body
respond but not as I've not seen I think
it's a great thing to look at I mean
okay sir you're the president and people
tuning in to these briefings they want
to get information and guidance and want
to know what to do they looking for a
murder I'm the president and your fake
news and you know what I'll say to you
I'll say very nicely I know you will I
know you will because I know the guy I
see what he writes he's a total faker so
are you ready are you ready are you
ready it's just a suggestion from a
brilliant lab by a very very smart
perhaps brilliant man he's talking about
son he's talking about heat and you see
the numbers so that's it that's all I
have I'm just here to present talent I'm
here to present ideas because we want
ideas to get rid of this thing
and if he is good and if sunlight is
good that's a great thing as far as I'm
concerned